so this goes to the chicken this goes to
the chickens can you eat it you and I
can eat it
[Music]
going vegan driving EVs and choosing
reusable cups are all better for the
planet but what do we do about piles and
piles of leftover groceries
one company is trying to tackle that
approximately 40 percent of all the food
that gets grown gets thrown away and if
food waste was a country it would be the
third largest greenhouse gas in there so
this is a big big problem and what we
are doing is we're actually collecting
all that Surplus grocery food from
supermarkets of course after any
donations can occur as the first and
best usage of food is be fed to humans
then the next best usage of that food is
to be upcycled at a facility like ours
into a chicken feed
oh
after food bank donations the closed
loop system starts at the supermarket
yeah so this is at Acme so they just
cold their aisle they help de-package
and then they put that food that Surplus
grocery food into these bins and this is
what then we are able to pick up every
two or three days from their storm
do you keep track of what supermarkets
what bin came from it's a great question
so actually you can see right here we
RFID track and Trace the bins we
actually provide this data back to the
supermarkets so they know actually on a
weekly basis how much food they're
actually throwing away so hopefully they
can waste less so they may purchase less
bananas after you show them that they're
actually buy more than they need
absolutely you can see the food
traveling up the conveyor system we have
people pulling out any foreign material
as well as we have a metal detector so
the product will go up there and they'll
get ground up and then the next step is
this big soup kind of kettle that we
have
about 160 tons of that food is created
into a liquid that then gets put into
these huge Vats about 6 000 gallons
we heat it up and then we put it on big
dryers and get it down to a usable form
that if you crumble it up it can get
pelletized into a chicken feed can you
eat it you and I can eat it
do I eat it
[Laughter]
it's Chase
a little salty like a Parmesan chip okay
parmesan that's a very nice
what we're really doing is a century
reverting nature back to the way it
intended to operate when we all used to
grow up on a farm we used to take our
leftovers and feed it to our chickens
out back they grew healthy they grew
great we're just taking that same
concept and now just bringing it to a
large-scale infrastructure level
it's the best tasting chicken I've ever
had and Chef after Chef had said the
same thing and it's not that surprising
better feed is going to give you a
better bird
says each do good chicken
Surplus groceries from being thrown away
and reduces three pounds of greenhouse
gases
how well leftover food often ends up in
landfills where it emits methane a
greenhouse gas 25 times more potent than
carbon dioxide at trapping heat in the
atmosphere which contributes to global
warming I ran food policy in the Obama
Administration I was also their chef so
cooked dinner for the family five nights
a week and now my life is focused on
climate change human health and Food
Systems I'm a father of two young kids
and
the prospect of leaving them a world
where they're going to struggle to feed
themselves or there might not be enough
water to to irrigate our crops it's
something that you know keeps me up at
night
so it's about really making climate
change tangible to all of us that we can
all do our part not change our habits
but yet eat a delicious piece of chicken
that now actually has a net positive
impact on the world
[Music]